Donald Trump has surrendered in Atlanta
any any minute now we're going to be
getting his mug shot so we'll see
everything good we're good we got
history in the making my friends and uh
we got a lot of talk about so uh we'll
we will we will probably be uh posting
this uh this mug shot as soon as it
comes in a lot of people are sharing a
fake one but we got the real one we also
have an individual who was indicted
alongside alongside Trump denied bail so
there are questions about what's going
to happen with Trump but we think he'll
probably just leave it's going to be
fairly routine but still historical and
I have a question as we kick this this
one off we've got a lot to talk about
Elon Musk is being sued by the
government because he only hires
Americans yeah he discriminates against
Asylum Seekers and refugees that's
amazing we've got uh follow-up on the
debate we've got stories about the Trump
Tucker interview everyone's clamoring
over the view count
we'll get into all that but I'll just
ask you one thing to uh to Stew on
before we get started
if Donald Trump is convicted in Georgia
or any jurisdiction let's say Georgia
because it's a state charge
and they demand jail time or even house
arrest ankle bracelet something right if
Trump is convicted on all of these
felonies certainly they're going to have
to take him into custody in some
capacity
what happens if likely the charges are
going to be over one year long
what happens if the charges extend
beyond the election but Donald Trump
wins and becomes the president now a
sitting duly elected president
is incarcerated at the state level does
Trump tell the feds no I'm walking out
of here today Federal supremacy clause
or does Trump just stay in jail and what
happens if Trump orders the feds
to shut down that jail and walk him out
even though he's been convicted in that
state
something to think about as we get into
all of this before we get started my
friends head over to castbrew.com
buy our coffee support the show by
buying our coffee directly I gotta be
honest Appalachian nights is my favorite
coffee ever I think it's it's the best
I've ever had it's my favorite but I
also really like rise with Roberto Jr
our
um our light roast breakfast blend we
got whole bean we got ground we've got
coffee pods the K-Cups you can put them
in your little machine press the button
make yourself a cup of coffee go to
casper.com if you want to support the
show there are products everything you
buy helps us I'm really excited we're
currently working on Alex Stein's
Primetime grind two times caffeine we're
gonna be launching that I'm really
excited for the Partnerships we've got
coming also head over to timcast.com
become a member click join us we're
gonna have a members only uncensored
show coming up soon but also heads up
right now
the timcast IRL Miami event tickets are
live and you it's it's only uh for
members for the first half an hour so if
you are not a member you either have to
wait or become a member and uh we gave
advance notice to our members a little
while ago
so that y'all can uh buy the tickets now
those that have been a member for a long
time we want you to get first priority
and and buying your tickets the event is
going to be amazing we got me Temple
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski Friday October
6th it's going to be at 5 30 doors open
and uh we had a lot A lot's gonna be
going on we're really excited and uh
we're really excited that I believe uh I
want to make sure we're we're being very
careful but uh Public Square is going to
be sponsoring the event we're huge fans
we love Public Square One of the most
powerful victories in the culture War
everything they're doing is fantastic
Public Square for those that aren't
familiar it's an app you download it it
shows you businesses that share your
values for bycotting so you can ignore
all these awful companies these brands
that hate your values hate families and
you go to Publix where you download the
app and you can see on a map all the
businesses in your area that believe in
America I love Public Square we're
really grateful it's an honor to have
them sponsoring us you guys should
download their app and and uh we're
gonna get into the news before we get
started smash the like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends and joining us today to talk
about this and and so much more is Eric
Hundley hey how you doing thanks for
having me man who are you what do you do
uh I'm co-host of the show America's
untold stories where we cover things
like JFK assassination RFK Jr or RFK
senior technically Alec Baldwin which
got me in trouble with the New Mexico
State prosecutor wow and many other sort
of things and I have another Channel
That's My Name where I interview folks
like John McAfee when he was on the Run
Carol Baskin of Tiger King and other
people like that right on well it should
be fun thanks for joining us it's a
historic day so it should get
interesting we got Hannah Claire hanging
out hi I'm Hannah clear brimlow I'm a
writer for timcast.com you should get
all of your news from timcast.com
exclusively in my opinion Phil's here
too hi I'm Phil Labonte I'm not Ian
Crossland I'm the lead singer of the
heavy metal band All That Remains and
I'm an anti-communist and encounter
revolutionary my friend Serge surge.com
checking in let Let's uh get started
it's quite a day let's just go into it
we have this uh tweet from Disclose TV
Trump arrives at the Fulton County jail
right now this is the entrance of the
jail and he's going to essentially have
his height taken his weight taken
they'll wipe down his hair and eye color
then what they'll do is they'll
electronically fingerprint him with a uh
it's like sort of a piece of glass
scanner not ink then his mug shot will
be taken and we will get that because
under the open records act it's public
record in Georgia so that's the latest
we also have this Trump's booking
details for the Fulton County Jail it's
kind of hard to see let's see if we can
make this image a little bit bigger and
uh it's just everything we already know
we've got violation of Rico solicitation
of violation of oath of public officer
and there's the bond Trump has
apparently already posted Bond so here's
what they say they say he's a white male
six foot three and 215 pounds
Eric just gave me this look uh so I take
it you don't agree it's an orange male
I'd say he's built like me not 215 I
wish 215 pounds is trending on Twitter
right now nobody's buying it yeah but
they weighed him but it came out early
right I don't never trust the government
any government organization never trust
him I guess I just asked him like how
much do you weigh I mean is this all
just a sham what's really going on I
gotta say uh history is happening right
before our very eyes Trump is headed to
be processed he's going to join the mug
shots of everyone else and um
man
my my thoughts on this as we await the
mug shot which we'll we'll post as soon
as it pops up I'm staring at it right
here
I mentioned this in the beginning of the
show in the intro but we'll say it here
for this particular segment and I'm
curious what y'all think so comment uh
Super Chat whatever
we talk about the potentials for civil
war Tucker Carlson got roasted for
asking Trump about Civil War Trump said
he didn't know but the passions are
really intense and the hatred's Really
intense
I don't know I know that Stephen Marsh
we cite him a lot because he wrote a
book about this we disagree in a lot of
things but we we agree in a lot of core
elements and so that's why I found it
particularly fascinating I think he's
seeing similar things to what we're
seeing and he says civil Strife not
Civil War that people are being killed
for political reasons tensions are
escalating but it's the period pre-civil
War
so I give you this scenario and I want
you to tell me what you think happens
because I don't know
Trump is convicted in Georgia State
charges relating to the election
he's sentenced to 16 months
but the sentence comes down in let's say
July they want to do the trial in March
let's say that happens we're we've got
other report more reporting that at
least one defendant's trial will be
October 23rd but let's say Trump let's
let's say Trump is October 23rd let's
say the trial concludes beginning of
January he gets convicted sentenced to
16 months let's say in any capacity he's
taken into custody whatever that may be
minimum security ankle bracelet can't
leave your house who knows if he's
convicted in Georgia they're not letting
him leave the state
Trump campaigns online Trump wins Trump
is President Trump is incarcerated
then what
I do not believe there's a scenario in
this circumstance where Trump does not
walk out of jail or walk out of his
house or wherever they're holding him of
course the already we heard Dan bongino
say that the circuit service has the
federal supremacy clause multiple that
give them they can make anything a
federally protected Zone
so I'd have to imagine
first you have to assume Trump will not
be convicted you have to assume that if
convicted Trump will not be jailed if
those criteria are met then you have to
assume Trump won't get elected a lot of
hurdles here
but I think Trump has a path to Victory
and if he's can if he's around this
indictment people are saying is going to
help him out
if Trump wins and is convicted at the
same time tell me how we do not get at
the very least Federal versus State
armed conflict I think really quickly
just one consideration isn't Brian
Kemper Republican yeah but so well yeah
right doesn't Trump immediately become
the head of the Republican party as
president and essentially Kemp can be
ordered to mute the damn sentence
problem over uh I don't think Kemp can
commute it has to go to a panel the
panel has to agree so and I wasn't like
Trump he might not but then the um both
houses are are pro-trump and they want
they're going after Fanny Willis I think
there's enough people to push it through
whether Kemp likes it or not I think so
I think that the the governors have that
kind of like autonomy don't they for
pardons well I mean my understanding is
Georgia it's a panel that has the
authority on on this like so my
understanding is that Kemp would have to
go to a panel and submit to them there's
other states I think Florida does this
too I could be wrong it varies by state
right right it's not just you know
absolute authority of the governor to
Pardon some states are some states
aren't some states the governor like in
the past was like we're gonna have a
panel decide to avoid corruption it
makes sense you don't want a governor to
be like he's my friend you're free to go
so you have a panel convened to make
sure it's on the level but uh a lot of
criteria would need to right there's a
lot more than just Trump wins the
election you also have to have trumpets
convicted jailed wins the election and
then the state rejects his attempt to
leave because he's been convicted but
then what Trump goes to the Secret
Service and says I want you to open the
doors let me out and they're going to be
like yes
and they're going to open the doors and
George what are they going to do again
it's here there's a bunch of different
possibilities and I'm saying I don't
know how this would play out but this is
the path they expect us to be on
Trump is the front runner they're hoping
he doesn't win they're also trying to
put him in jail in prison not just a
prison of course if these two things
Collide you're gonna have the worst case
scenario federal agents in front of a
state jail with state troopers armed
saying back off we're not letting you
take a prisoner out and the FEDS being
like Trump is free to go he's the
president well in the US Army in the
National Guard and pretty much
everything else because they are
I think there are laws that they cannot
intrude with his ability to perform his
job so how is he going to meet with
world leaders in prison are they going
to roll them in hey um how do you
inaugurate him to have the inauguration
in jail in Georgia I mean I think this
entire thing was written by the
screenwriters of the show Scandal which
started Kerry Washington that was just a
political drama right it's so crazy to
think that this is the extent that they
are willing to go to where it won't even
make sense how do we proceed forward
right it kind of to me shows what a
mockery all of this is there are three
other places that Trump has been
indicted what are they gonna do after
this like it seems ludicrous and yet
this is what the Democrats think they
have to do to retain control of the
country I don't know I don't know that I
think that it's the motivated by the
Democrats actually worrying about
uh Trump beating him I honestly I don't
think that their their motivation is oh
he might win again I really do think
their motivation is we need to frighten
people that might push back against the
you know the bureaucracy I really think
that the the motivation is these if if
Americans believe that they can elect
someone that actually will be able to
affect the bureaucracy that's bad for us
so we want to deter that as much as
possible whether that means throwing
January six people into Jail uh shooting
75 year old men uh from Utah or throwing
their political rivals in jail okay both
well I mean obviously all of them but
that but that's my point I really don't
think that it's I think there's less
fear of him getting elected and more a
show of force this is there's in in the
past 10 or 15 years there have been a
lot of things that have
pushed back against the federal
government's power like the Bundy
standoff was a significant pushback
against the federal government's power
and they lost that granted they killed
one or one or two of them afterwards but
the actual first standoff they lost that
and that's you know they haven't lost
the standoff since you know or that I
can't think of the last time no they
they won Ruby Ridge sort of
they killed the people but it killed
their reputation that caused irreparable
harm to the FBI led into Waco sadly led
into Timothy McVeigh and I would say led
into the feds calming down for a while I
mean history repeats itself yeah we're
in 1968 again right now even with an RFK
Jr there was a lot more bombings well
that's true absolutely
we have other things that's true too
that's true and the internet plays a
substantial a large role in what's
happening too psychological manipulation
sock puppets Etc that's so you know I
was thinking about this too with Elon
getting rid of the block feature and I
kind of think he didn't explain it well
enough but I did realize something
non-verified accounts are de-ranked so
you have less to worry about with with
Spam accounts and things like that
because they're not going to appear high
in your timeline anyway so that is that
is a net positive I would add uh
a component of it why bring that up is
it means that
a lot of these fake accounts these sock
puppets that are just intending to
manipulate people for political causes
are going to be less impactful based on
the moves that Elon is making on x
that's true I might only worry about the
blocking if we get into that but is
there's the issue of people who follow
your account for the sole purpose of
interacting with people you do follow or
people who interact with you so like you
post him and somebody is a motivated
actor and everybody who responds to you
or likes it they hit it and then they
hit that account didn't you know that
Tim Poole did this then you know he did
this because we actually have stalkers
who do that no it's like blocking it's
very handy to say look you can do what
you want you can say what you want but I
you're not going to use me to harass my
friends I don't like the idea of getting
rid of the block button but at the same
time I don't know what he's actually
doing to it right like because there's
going to be other fun they've talked
about there's going to be other
functions like Lindo is saying there's
gonna be other functions they're gonna
be rolling out so I assume it won't be
the same kind of block button but I also
assume that they're going to address the
things that people have concerns with
because he doesn't want people being
like Oh yeah I would go and use x but
all I get is inundated with hate or
whatever he doesn't want people leaving
so whatever the the thing he decides to
do it's not going to be something that
most users don't like because well I
don't imagine that's gonna be something
that most users don't like because
they're very responsive responsive to
the users so we'll see and I just don't
I'm not going to go ahead and try to
guess what what it's going to be like
after they actually get rid of it yeah I
tend to think getting rid of the block
button is bad because you want the users
to be able to control their profile as
much as possible if someone is getting
blocked like crazy sure I'm surely the
back end of Twitter can look into that
if they want to part of it is because I
don't trust the Twitter CEO and so I
feel like she has already made it clear
that she is going to have her own
um strategy for allowing some people's
content to reach uh other users and and
for others to say sort of held back and
so the block feature taking away right
after that kind of information makes it
feel like they are really trying to take
the power out of the user's hands I
think Trump is out already nope they're
already leaving so now we're just I
think and I think now we're just waiting
for the mug shot to drop but Jason
Miller says that Donald Trump will be
speaking momentarily so we have this up
and we're just waiting to see uh what
happens in the meantime
uh I guess we'll just I hope he speaks
from the prison doors at the airport
already oh are they yeah Jason Miller
posted a photo in front of uh Trump
Force One and he says that uh Trump will
be speaking momentarily so really
interested to see uh what trumpets is
saying he's already I think this
Miller's already posted photos going
into and out of so I think I think
Trump's out already
I think he's out I'm sure I mean a
secret service no secret service would
not be playing maybe like get this done
now move movement yeah I can't yeah like
time is a thing for them as well I
imagine you're right I think magina was
right and Trump should not have posted
no I agree he should have just been like
do it
because then they would have been like
oh what do we what do you do yeah my
show me Mark Robert Rings a good point
too why are all these Republicans
running to Georgia to surrender like
Lemmings why aren't they saying screw
you come get me well this is what I was
saying Trump should go to Mar-A-Lago he
should say I've heard the reports on the
television
they can serve me with whatever legal
papers they want and when they do I'll
respond this would serve two purposes
one he's not gonna surrender two it
would put Ron DeSantis in in in a
decision dilemma DeSantis either has to
protect or abandon Trump in that regard
is he going to allow the extradition of
trump from Mar-A-Lago instead Trump just
says okay you know we'll go I think uh I
think Trump's thought about it but but I
wonder sometimes because I don't think
he's as strategic as a lot of people
think he is he's impulsive right and and
I think he's probably just like okay
we'll go do it I I think there's there's
like Little Resistance there there's
little conflict it's just like we'll go
do it but I wonder if they're thinking
if they just go through with this and
keep putting the pressure on on the
Democrats to take these actions
they come out looking like the victims
like they're being attacked it's
political martyrdom if that was the case
though Trump should not have posted
posted Bond he should have said no you
arrest me if you think I did something
wrong yeah I think that's an interesting
point uh I think a lot of people get
advised to surrender so that they look
compliant right like if you're if you're
being accused of being a criminal
Enterprise that's like trying to
overthrow the government then you want
to look like no no we respect the
government and what they ask us to do uh
but I think there are probably kind of
Bolder steps that could have been taken
I am kind of amused by how much of a a
joke this already appears like I think
Chris Bertman had a tweet that was like
this Brady Bunch reunion looks crazy and
it's all of the mug shots that have come
out like it's the being able to see this
like wave of people that you're familiar
with in these mugshots does have sort of
a ludicrous effect people are sharing it
you know America's mayor for God's sake
yeah from 9 11 to in a tie and a mug
shot it's like Jason Miller just posted
a photo of trump boarding Air Force One
as Signature Flight Support a private
Airline terminal provides the private
terminal and there are photos going
around they are fake mug shots and now
there are other photos going around that
people are claiming are real
Phil just showed me one I don't think
it's real
I don't think it's a real mug shot
you don't think so
we're let's pull it over let's pull it
over The Newsroom is waiting to post an
article about this with its mug shot so
I'm hoping that they'll let me know all
the other ones had a had a badge but
this looks it actually looks closer
lighting wise though they're fake and
it's no but this is a photo of a photo
so yeah they may have taken the mug shot
and then someone snapped a pic on their
phone yeah that's interesting
I can't see him doing that as the mug
shot though well it could be someone
inside that just snug a quick snap and
sent it out to their friends do you
think he's gonna smile or you think he's
gonna look serious you look serious I
think stoic but not not scowling I I
don't know that doesn't feel like Trump
there's a couple people that smiled
doing wrong shots and I read some
headline today I was like why are they
doing this why are this is not a joke
it's kind of yeah
people are saying that that's another
fake mugshot so we'll just uh we'll I'll
keep the uh the Twitter feed ready for
when that drops and as soon as Trump
starts speaking we'll uh we'll grab his
speech in the time being though we got
another story and this is where it gets
crazy ladies and gentlemen director of
black voices for Trump is held in jail
without bond Harrison Floyd becomes the
first Maga Ally to be booked behind bars
in the Georgia election fraud case no
bond
they're starting light I think they're
not locking everybody up because they're
they're slow rolling it they know they
can't shock the system but yo this story
is crazy look at this he says apparently
FBI went to his house to serve him and
he said who the f Do You Think You Are
Floyd allegedly screamed the affidavit
says describing that Floyd was standing
chest to chest with the agent after
knocking him back with his body in
Georgia Floyd is accused
alongside Steven cliffguard Lee a police
chaplain and trevian cootie Kanye West's
former publicist of pressuring poll
worker Ruby Freeman into falsely saying
she committed election fraud Freeman and
her daughter Shea Moss who gave tearful
testimony to the house Select Committee
in January 6 were subjects of a
conspiracy theory echoed by Trump and
his allies this is the crazy thing did
these people genuinely believe she
committed fraud and they were going to
her being like what did you do we saw
videos is that a criminal act
and now I got quite I don't I don't
trust the government apparently they're
saying that he assaulted an FBI agent he
was charged with attacking an FBI agent
well I strongly recommend you don't do
that who was working with special on
special counsel Jack Smith's parallel
probe in 2020 election appearance by
Trump and his allies The Washington Post
reported Wednesday and having David says
Floyd Body slammed an agent who arrived
at his Rockville Maryland home to
subpoena him before a Federal grand jury
in Washington DC so my question is
what is he being charged with in Georgia
right held without bond in Georgia he
was charged with rackets hearing
conspiracy solicit false statements and
influencing Witnesses so the FBI thinks
a totally different case he's being
charged very similar to many many of
these other defendants and they're not
letting him out
things are getting crazy ladies and
gentlemen the krasensteins you gotta
love them they have no limit
they will feign reasonableness and then
they're like I agree with the charges
against Trump's lawyers for the simple
fact they provided him legal counsel and
it's just like I'm like dude you guys
have to have a limit right like what is
they're going to start rounding people
up onto trains and the Crescent scenes
are going to be like well now hold on we
don't know exactly why they're rounding
people up let's give them the benefit of
the doubt dude they are arrest Jenna
Ellis is being criminally charged under
Rico for simply being Trump's lawyer
that's it she didn't do anything else
that's it part of a conspiracy insane
think about it at work so because now
everybody's going to be afraid to
represent Trump or any uh Republican
figure or anybody else so it's effective
which is exactly which goes back to my
point that I was making before you know
I really think this is about
intimidation I said this you know a
couple nights ago too The Establishment
as in when I say The Establishment I
mean the bureaucracy it's in DC and
likely the Democrat Party and their
allies in the media they don't want
people to defend Trump they want people
to be afraid to associate with Trump the
Trump statement is up let's play the
video it's only one minute long ladies
and gentlemen here it is
they did very well to have him just walk
up to them
challenge an election I thought the
election was a rigged election a stolen
election and I should have every right
to do that as you know you have many
people that you've been watching over
the years through the same thing whether
it's Hillary Clinton or Stacy Abrams or
many others
when you uh have that great freedom to
challenge you have to be able to
otherwise you get a very dishonest
elections what has taken place here is
the travesty of Justice we did nothing
wrong I did nothing wrong and everybody
knows it I've never had such support and
that goes with the other ones too what
they're doing is election interference
they're trying to interfere with an
election there's never been anything
like it in our country before this is
their way of campaigning and this is one
instance but you have three other
instances it's election interference
I agree and my question is this if the
Democrats are campaigning As Trump said
off of this and they are this uh this
Fulton D.A launched a fundraiser
then Republicans will have no choice but
to campaign on the exact same issue in
the other direction and if the Democrats
are saying vote for us and we will
imprison anyone you hate and the Trump
supporters are saying we will get
revenge and go after those who are
weaponizing the legal system where where
does this end it doesn't it's like a
South Korea from wunderstand
um the last several leaders have all
been in prison so it's like as soon as
the next party gets in the last party
guy gets locked up and it sounds like
Illinois yeah
oh yeah yeah
but I don't think it ends with with just
getting locked up the Democrats are
saying we will crush you the Republicans
mostly sitting on their hands but if a
Tit for Tat does arise
if Trump gets reelected
the Revenge will not just be on the Deep
state for everything they did during his
first term it's going to be on everyone
right now for everything they're doing
yeah I feel like Camp's gonna have a
really hard time uh when Trump gets
elected he'll be federally indicted how
could he not if Trump gets uh here's my
prediction if Trump gets reelected
election fraud charges across the board
and tons of Governors face maybe not
tons of maybe a handful we're probably
going to see a bunch of democrat
officials I imagine they'll be charged
if Trump wins I cannot imagine a man so
obsessed with 2020 does not remain
obsessed with 2020 and then as we've
already seen you can indict a ham
sandwich okay so the people were like
there's no evidence Trump wouldn't be
able to do it yeah that's not an issue
if Trump gets in and he gets a an AG
that is totally on board you're gonna
see whatever they need pop up and there
will be charges
assume that this makes
even more appealing to people who are
generally critical of the Criminal
Justice System right like people who
feel like it's corrupted already for
non-political reasons are looking at
what's happening to Trump and saying oh
yeah so he's experienced it too none of
us are safe he is I in some ways
becoming more of a a candidate for
people I would assume would typically
vote for the Democratic party because
they're always saying we'll fix this and
Republicans are trying to lock you up
yeah exactly I I'm I do not share your
optimism about new voter new Trump
voters but um that being said one of the
things that I noticed that I really
liked that he said he said I believed it
was a rigged election and it was that
kind of uh verbiage articulating it
properly really really really really
really really matters because they are
going to have to try to convince the
jury that he believed that he lost and
that he believed that it was a fair loss
and he knew he was violating the law
they have to prove to a jury that what
he what he believed it's approved what
was in his head and the only person that
can screw that up is Donald Trump yeah
you know his lawyers were like oh my
goodness thank goodness he said it the
right way he there's no ad-lib here
because it he's already got oh he's
already loaded against him he's got a
bunch of a bunch of things stacked
against him in the when it comes to
people Prosecuting himself and if he's
not minding his p's and q's he can put
himself in significant into a
significant problem well I hope that
when when Trump wins reelection assuming
he does
as he begins
instructing the AG to go after people we
get a really cool Montage with like
Staying Alive by the Bee Gees and just
having sunglasses putting them on and
then there's like a montage of like
indicted indicted Trump should have
indicted people in his first term Trump
should have launched investigations when
they were investigating him for Russia
gate he should have immediately said we
are going to investigate the lies Trump
should have countered immediately and
I'm not I'm not ragging on him for not
not knowing at the future I'm saying
hindsight is 20 20. Trump could have
said my fellow Americans
currently
there are political partisans that are
accusing the highest office in this
country of being subservient to Vladimir
Putin and the Russians this is sedition
This Is A Lie the American people have
spoken
so we will be bolstering the
investigation into these claims but
making sure it is holistic and covers
all ground and we figure out who is
pushing the narrative and why he could
have said yeah yeah I'm on board here's
my guy joining in and then gone after
democrats for the Steele dossier for
instance why did it take so long for us
to figure out that Hillary Clinton was
the one backing that stuff
well I needed people to tell him to do
that because keep in mind he was not a
politician if Tucker Carlson had just
said it one time
Tucker you know then Trump would have
been like you know I was watching Tucker
he says I should investigate I'll do it
and then he would have done it and we
wouldn't be here right now come on
Tucker what are you doing no I mean I
think the there are a lot of things that
I wish Trump had done while he was in
office and obviously we can't go back
um my concern would be that he doesn't
do something going forward so if he's
re-elected I would like to see some kind
of action I mean you were saying before
the show that uh Jim Jordan's
investigation for on Fannie Willis you
felt like maybe he should have called it
earlier oh yeah hello what time is it I
mean how long ago was he charged is
Congress that slow you can't put it
together you can't say hey you know what
Fannie um how about you come up here
Thursday
how about the Thursday the 24th come on
in front of Congress that would have
been beautiful so while Trump is getting
arrested Fannie could be testified in
front of Congress and enjoying her day
in another location
yeah new thought because I assume she's
down there hanging out with all her
friends being like our work is
accomplished good job everybody and she
should be sweating bullets but they're
doing nothing
right well I should I shouldn't say
they're doing nothing they are doing
something I think I have the uh story
right here
from Forbes GOP LED house Judiciary
Committee opens investigation into
Fannie Willis so I don't know what else
you can ask for I think they should
subpoena her and immediately call it
like you said it looks like they're just
once again being like we are going to be
opening an inquiry into whether we
should inquire about Fanny Willis right
the republican-led house Judiciary
Committee launched an investigation into
Fulton County Georgia district attorney
Fanny Willis as former president Donald
Trump surrenders himself to authorities
after Willis's office indicted him we
get it
this is Jim Jordan sent a strongly
worded letter to Willis Thursday asking
her to turn over information to the
committee writing her indictment of
trump and his allies involve substantial
Federal interests the letter claims
Wilson's indictment appears to be an
attempt to use state criminal law to
regulate the conduct of federal
officials acting in their official
capacities and raises whether Willis was
coordinating with Federal prosecutors in
the Justice Department regarding her
investigation
they got Trump on federal charges they
they're going to they're going to go
after his lawyers the question is will
the Supreme Court intervene under uh
this argument that Trump was acting in
His official duties as a member of the
executive branch and thus they are
interfering with the federal government
supreme court I imagine is going to say
get out of here with this right they
have to
quash it or what I don't know it's a
strongly worded letter though so I'm
sure everybody's quivering
it cracks me panic ensues as soon as you
get a strongly worded letter I mean I
I'm sure that she's laughing they're
probably passing around the office look
at this look at this guys check out the
letter he sent me a letter leaving a
subpoena
for a subpoena yeah and this is all they
can muster up
exactly so he's being arrested
she gets a letter not they don't quite
equate do they I mean it's frustrating
you were talking I believe earlier today
about uh leftist tactics oh yeah
especially within the riot and that was
making me think of something because my
friend Mark
um show partner he's he grew up in that
ilk and he kind of Switched parties over
time and he's like you need to follow
leftist tactics because they are
effective and he's like why the hell
don't Republicans do it and I understand
the conservative mindset well it's not
dignified and that's the problem is the
conservatives are like that's unseemly
meanwhile Democrats are taking dumps in
the streets in San Francisco Bingo yeah
and Republicans are like well I never
and then they're like as the crackpots
take a dump right in the middle of the
street they're like huh we should arrest
that guy and then all of a sudden the
cops show up at your house and you're
like how could you arrest me I've done
nothing as Republicans for you they
should you know honestly I would like it
if every single Republican was arrested
just every single one of them there you
go and this is like oh maybe now you'll
do do something be harder for them to do
something I think but I think I know you
mean I think there is a lot of like we
shouldn't stoop to their level we have
the moral High Ground on the other hand
it's really hard to defend the moral
High Ground when you are actively losing
territory on every yeah on every other
front you are seeding power so we gotta
we have to have a Reconciliation
somewhere no well you've got to have
ground to hold any High Ground I mean
there is no ground if if they're like
okay cool and then they just push them
over and you know you brought that up
very poignantly about the tactics things
of that sort oh I mean the the leftist
tactics are Advanced conservative
right-wing libertarian Etc just
non-existent the left does stuff like
Optics they understand Optics so they'll
get one of their quote-unquote
journalists
a video will come out during a cop
beating some guy and they'll be like
help help police brutality and what the
video won't show you is the guy punching
the cop first because the person filming
it will edit that out specifically to
create propaganda and they refer to
themselves in the activist Community not
as journalists but as propagandists then
publicly they'll say they're a
journalist to cover themselves because
what was it vashu said he'll do anything
to win or something like that yeah he's
essentially I mean his his philosophy is
a consequentialist so essentially the
the philosophy boils down to and this is
just a wave tops kind of idea but it
boils down to the results are what
really matters so how you get there
doesn't that's and that's part of why
likes and socialists tend to have that
philosophy a lot because it's how they
deal with the horrors of socialism
they're like well once we get to the
Socialist Utopia the millions and piles
of dead don't matter because then no one
else will die because of whatever the
failings of capitalism that they're you
know because our cult has established
its goal except what happens is once
they use these evil tactics to gain
power they fear someone else using these
tactics to be in power so they maintain
an authority regime which they were once
fighting against they just become the
new authoritarian regime and they get
mad when you point it out well because
they know that what they just did
yesterday somebody's going to do to them
exactly because they know the same
tactics yep so um yeah it's a good
survival mechanism I mean the system
overall doesn't work it's low trust
people to get thrown into prison for
nothing you know people use the
government to remove their uh Rivals
that are are just in business or if
someone's got a nicer office than you
and you can call the government be like
yo he had you know he was saying things
that are against the party and the party
comes and Picks Them Up and next thing
you know you get the job now I mean that
kind of stuff happened all the time all
over the Eastern Bloc countries in in
when the Soviet Union was or when it was
communist countries you know when they
were all satellites of the Soviet Union
I don't know man there the reason
there's a Fighting Chance is only
because and I'm not trying to rag on
conservatives but it's only because
dissidents from the left have switched
sides uh art culture and organizational
uh prowess are coming greatly from
people who used to be liberals and left
who are now fed up and working with
conservatives you know with all due
respect Ben Shapiro is still a rather
stodgy dude right yeah he's uh he's a
guy in a suit who's very
um
I don't know preppy I guess you know the
way we would describe it in schools and
I mean that with all due respect like
he's a he's a proper clean-cut
well-mannered man but that's the people
like I don't know Phil you're a rock
star you know what people are into right
I mean some yeah but they're like people
want people want some Freedom they want
some entertainment they want some Edge
they want some punk rock and now that
like what it was it Johnny Rotten yeah
literally John Biden right wing and he's
like it's the it's the left that have
become insufferable yeah and and
you'll you're starting to see people in
you know in the more
edgy kind of uh genres of music and
stuff like that starting to push back
you see you know like the guys in the
defiant oh that's great the defiant and
uh people were talking about Ronnie
Radke and Tommy vexed who pushes back
against that kind of stuff I've been
pushing back against this kind of stuff
forever
um and it's falling out of favor
um they people don't want to be told how
they have to interact with everyone they
come into contact with they want to know
they want to be like look I'm going to
be polite and I'm going to try to be
nice and I want to get along with people
but if someone
mispronounces a word or says the wrong
word or says you know says something
that's newly insensitive they don't have
to worry about losing their job they
don't have to worry about the
repercussions they don't have to worry
about being debanked and these are real
things now obviously the people that get
debanked of the people that really push
back against the narrative and stuff but
it's only a certain it's only for so
long because as that type of tactic
becomes something that works it happens
more people will do it more and if the
government get if they if they see that
it works the government will get into
the business of it social credit scores
will come here they are currently
they're in China right now that is a
real threat they're here now it's just
being controlled by private entities
look at PayPal
right yeah to some degree yeah well it
doesn't matter it's a weird situation
where people are like oh well we're
going to worry about the corporation
things like that well the corporations
are driving this you have PayPal who is
literally doing a social credit score
and taking people's money and then as
far as punk rock well punk rock is
against Authority so who's in Authority
right now right so punk rock is going to
be obviously right wing if left wing is
an authority left-wing liberal
establishment neocons Etc
yeah and it's it's it's not even about
is this a funny thing the left will
immediately say you're claiming that
conservative Christians who are wearing
suit are punk rock no we're saying that
anybody who's truly punk rock who would
say I don't know wasn't it Sid Vicious
who wore a swastika t-shirt yeah that
would not fly with neolibs with the
liberal and left establishment they'd
lose their minds if someone dared do
that punk rock was intending to offend
you you like you know and so now these
these all these Hall Monitor types
deeply offended by naughty words they're
the antithesis of punk rock that's like
the funniest thing it's like I'll give a
shout out to Hassan who is like
it's funny because he is more like
what's the what's the right word for Ben
Shapiro right what's the word nerd no no
no no no no no no no no no no I'm
talking about a guy who is clean cut
unmannered button up Hassan is 10 times
more stodgy and buttoned up than Ben
Shapiro is there is this veneer among
the left of being edgy but they're
marching around chanting amazon.com
slogans and Walmart slogans and being
and it's just like we have this I just
absolutely love Hassan calling in
Crossland a conservative that just right
there shows you that it is a thin veneer
of grifting bro any reasonable person
leftists for instance they call Ian Moon
Lord because they know he's a hippie
dippy Crystal Weirdo And he Rags on
Trump all the time who in their right
mind would call this guy conservative
unless you're a grifter just saying
whatever you think you need to say to
earn internet points or your tribe and
you're a cult because if you're an
occult if anybody Strays from the cult
or tribal narrative they're gone yeah
but it only takes one even among woke
leftists they call Ian moonlord
right they like these socialists who are
very woke are like yeah Ian's not a
conservative he's a weirdo he's a hippie
weird they call him Moon Lord they laugh
about it and they like sometimes when he
when he yells at Trump and stuff Hassan
is just
I'm gonna say whatever you know if
you're a on B I'm just gonna say
whatever I think people are gonna you
know click on he is like he is as
establishment as establishment can be
he's the dude in high school wearing the
Letterman jacket pushing around the
Nerds that son's got some serious
audience capture he is terrified of his
chat his chat runs him like Matt if he
says something if he says something the
chat doesn't like the chat will let him
know and and he will quickly evolve the
what he's saying ladies and gentlemen
the mug shot has arrived in fact that
image we saw was real it was real it was
a photo of a photo of the mug shot and
CNN is reporting this is the Fulton
County mugshot of Donald Trump this
photo is history in the making and I'm
sure it will be on a plethora of
t-shirts yeah and posters I would uh uh
you know you guys feel free to make this
but um I think we'll we'll make one
we'll take that image of trump we'll put
it on a poster so it looks like the
Obama hope poster but it'll say Revenge
instead yeah and I would like to put one
of those posters up and probably just
how can we give them out for free can we
like give posters of trouble such as
Revenge we could just do a mailing like
yeah you could do a PDF and people could
print it themselves in all sizes right
and then anyone can just take it that's
a good idea so I don't know do we have
anything from the crew listening they
can just make it and then we'll just
publish it and be like there you go
Revenge yeah I like it the mug shot is
here
you know and some people were saying the
uh fourth
the fourth surrender would be
meaningless and it would not matter nah
this is this is it this is the moment
the other ones were like slow build up
this right now with the mug shot well
this is unpardonable so this has the
teeth I mean New York is unpardable
State charges but it wasn't election
related right this is this is
clearly political for one simple reason
the most famous man in the world does
not need a mug shot
Trump can't walk down a street in Peru
and not like Trump can be in Utica
how do you pronounce it in Alaska and
they're going to be like Trump Trump
trump could be in the Aleutian Islands
an abandoned military base and if anyone
walks by for any reason maybe maybe yo
the only place Trump can go where they
need a mugshot North Sentinel Island
all right oh you can't do you get there
you go
but that's the only place in the world
except for like uncontacted Amazon
tribes I guess but if Trump went to set
north central island they'd be like who
are you actually they wouldn't say
English they'd just be like
what is this like it's a it's some crazy
guy did you see us truth about that no
what did he say oh God it was hilarious
he was talking about he goes
I have to put up a bond because I'm a
Flight Risk and he said well gee I
wonder would I possibly leave be leaving
on my plane my ever unrecognizable plane
with a giant branding on it he goes no
perhaps I should fly commercial because
no one would recognize me there go
Incognito yeah yes it was it was
hilarious it's dumb I mean this is
something true Trump proves over and
over again which is that he is the
entity
in and of himself he's recognizable and
people will flock to wherever he is the
Tucker interview had what 100 million
views and less than eight hours yeah
it's at like 220. it's insane people
want to know what he's doing there's no
way that he would just not be noticed if
he tried to sneak out of the country and
also he's running for president so he
probably doesn't want to leave he
probably wants to be here on purpose I
think the mug shot is just for Democrats
to fundraise on it I don't think it'd be
a good idea for him to campaign to
people in in like somewhere in South
America I think he can do whatever he
wants to hear the America first
president you want to stay in America
he's going to take a secret service
detail with him on his flight it's just
so ludicrous why is there a bond yeah
and why is there a flight rate
intimidates people this isn't all about
government intimidation why isn't the
bond higher that's my current one like
it should be 200 million
if it was a legit Bond yup it would be
200 million or two billion dollars
because he really is a Flight Risk and
it's a problem but 200 000 that's pocket
change imagine a mob boss and died on
all these counts Rico they would not let
him go they're anyone else and that is
not even high crimes if it's like the
mob boss was engaged in a criminal
Enterprise where they were selling drugs
you know and they were organizing and
doing this and doing that we believe it
he's a major Flight Risk We're not gonna
let him out they'd be like yup and the
lawyer would argue be like how dare you
blah blah is innocent women guilty and
they'd be like we have a preponderance
of evidence Donald Trump's accused of
trying to overthrow the government
you'd think for that they'd be like wait
oh this guy anywhere we're going to cut
off his Communications he's danger nope
they're like you're free to go sir have
a nice day because it's political they
want to campaign off his mug shot as
much as Trump wants to campaign off his
mug shot the danger is if both sides are
using civil Conflict for fundraising and
and generating votes it only ends in one
place you eventually end up with a
politician saying look
they said vote for me and I will put
them in prison Trump trump said it first
and then didn't do it then they said it
and now they're doing it Trump get gets
reelected Revenge he starts doing it
then they're gonna say it's illegitimate
at what point does someone say no and
then there's a clash I gotta tell you
I'm looking at these videos and I'm
having scary Eerie feelings what is the
legitimacy of the squad car in front of
the jail
taking Donald Trump in on these BS fake
charges the police in Georgia
my fear is the actions they have just
taken there's a photo of them like
Trump's walking out in there in front of
them and things like that it makes them
look like they're illegitimate and they
have no Authority
I'm imagining this scenario
a police officer is imagine this there's
a cop standing on the side of the street
a homeless man walks up and says I want
you to arrest that woman he goes you got
a boss and then he goes and does it and
you're watching it happen being like
why are you arresting that woman that's
just some random homeless guy
what we have here is that's my analogy
I don't understand
how they can expect to maintain
a view of legitimacy of law enforcement
when one crime is skyrocketing people
are ransacking Nike stores and malls and
and grocery stores and they're not
arresting these people
with the covet lockdowns they punished
regular innocent people and already
conservatives were outraged there's the
videos of the cops stomping on The Thin
Blue Line Flags
now you have more than half the country
slightly more that believe this is
politics this is political and
illegitimate and they watch a police
officer engage in plainly political
illegitimate Behavior the only thing now
stopping people from disrespecting the
rule of law is a fear of violence that
was a large component of it but there
was often I would say in this country
there was a fear of a a respect of
authority and a fear of being shunned by
the community so it wasn't just the cops
could assert force over you for many
people it was but for a lot of regular
law-abiding citizens it was it's the
wrong thing to do we respect the police
the police don't respect you the police
are letting criminals run rampant the
police arrested that poor young man in
New York who tried to save people on a
train the police arrested Kyle
Rittenhouse they put him in jail
how could anyone watch what they're
doing to a former president and think
the police are acting in a legitimate
way
I when I looked at the live video that
outside outside the jail and you've got
the squad car there I'm just like it
looks like clown car to me I just I
don't feel it anymore I do not feel it
it feels like these cops are are
derelict it feels like they are
illegitimate and that worries me because
if I'm seeing this now and I'm not even
the biggest Trump guy I can't imagine
what anyone else is thinking about it no
it's impossible I mean you're you're the
history guy here does this remind you of
anything else
not in this country no
um other countries yeah that's that's
now I'm interested what other countries
yeah like um you've got Brazil you know
the most recently with Lula and yeah I
mean Glenn Greenwald talks about it and
then uh from my understanding Korea has
been doing it it's common and you know
Eastern Bloc countries things like that
but what about historically
you know when countries Fall Into
Revolution regime change war Civil War I
mean a lot of people have said there are
similarities between this and the
Spanish Civil War I think
that's I've heard that the most
that this that what's going on here
tracks alongside the Spanish Civil War
more than anything else
I haven't followed it so I'll take your
word for it I don't know I don't know
anything about it it just seems bizarre
that this would be the route that you
know we take now I mean I was reading
CNN today and they were saying this is
unprecedented first first time in
history something like this has happened
you want to say you think that's a good
thing like do you think this is the
direction you want to take the country
if you're the party that's in power is
this the precedent you want to set I
mean theoretically if the scales it back
Trump's elected or novel how many times
have you heard the word that's novel
charges we've never seen a virus no safe
charges never um the RICO Act is novel
Jack Smith is novel
which means we're making this up as
we go
where is any Republican to do the
smallest bit
don't get me wrong like federally we got
Jim Jordan saying you know I I hereby
Demand with a strongly worded letter
I want to see what you've got in your
documents and it's live well she
probably crumbled that up and throw it
in the trash blew her nose in it first
where's the subpoena at the state level
where are the indictments you've got uh
let me you're gonna say something oh I
was just going to ask do any of the like
the stronger word letter is obviously
ridiculous but at the same time does he
have to issue it to give her a chance to
turn over the documents before he can
get a subpoena like I don't know what
the I'm not sure because there is
questioning her could be part of the
investigation right I mean we want to
bring you in and talk to you about
what's going on because how do we
determine what we're charging or what
we're actually writing out right get
your ass over here we got a problem come
come on up here it is crazy that she's
not in DC answering questions take a
look at this from Eddie Johnson
he tweeted this earlier breaking Fulton
County D.A Fanny Willis regularly
questioned election results and used her
office to push unfounded conspiracies on
the eve of Trump's arrest in Georgia for
challenging an election a deep dive into
the prosecutor's history of doing the
same thing here's one post he said
Georgia could determine who is our next
president a team of lawyers needs to
watch them count every single vote they
can start in Fulton where we are having
water leaks what ballots are they
throwing out Georgia let's give an
honest accounting no stunts
he goes on a mansion a deep dive shows
that she is a hard and radical activist
not an unbiased attorney her page is
littered with BLM propaganda
Fulton County D.A Fannie Wells blatantly
and quite illegally used her office for
partisan political activity imagine
thinking you'll get just from a person
who is a proud Democrat there you go
with the mug father is a black panther
really you didn't know that yes her
father was literally a black panther you
know the people who ran around with the
Weather Underground those folks
every for the past 10 years we've heard
people screaming and freaking out about
like Nazis and the right and blah blah
and yet the organizations that were
actually mailing bombs around the United
States in the 60s and 70s well all of
their progeny all of the children of
that movement all of the people that
were informed by the thinkers of that
movement those people are in positions
of power and in positions of authority
and Academia and they're making New
Radicals and they're there still there's
still teaching in Chicago and still
writing Obama's book I mean everything
is fine don't worry about it they're not
radical at all the the amount of of red
washing that has happened to America uh
to Americans is ridiculous and and
even with like McCarthyism in the 50s
and stuff and still there's been a
massive amount of red washing together
all the mark like Pro communism red
washing people just like hiding or or
downplaying communist influence and and
communist Theory and stuff like that and
and
talking about communist Theory or like
you know leftist Theory and stuff like
that but not telling people where it
comes from that it or making the
connection to the thinkers that so like
they'll they'll talk about like say the
in the influence was this this person
right but they don't tell you that this
person's uh their their their uh Mentor
or whatever was someone like Angela
Davis or someone like Mark Herbert
Marquis or whatever people that are well
known as leftist thinkers I can't
remember his name but the CIA director
no they're really nasty one you look
like a bulldog if you hold up a
photograph of him he looks like a full
Bulldog he literally voted for the
Communists yeah he was a communist yeah
that's and I think I think he voted for
Angela Davis probably he was yeah he was
Communist so well one of my favorite
examples of this was uh there was a
couple years ago a non-profit it wasn't
the ADL but some like research group put
out a study on domestic terrorism and
they said you know right wing extremism
white supremacy is is what's leading the
country in domestic terrorism but they
wouldn't release the data that they used
they they wouldn't release it so anyone
could verify it and they also excluded
any environmental terrorism so anything
like whether underground they didn't
count and so the the data that they're
working off of is inaccurate but then
they report the headline to freak people
out they want you to be misled on
purpose and I think that's the biggest
issue that the average American has
which is that they don't have time to
comb through everything and so they end
up relying on the headlines and the
headlines are based on false information
and Elon Musk said they're going to get
rid of headlines on X and I think it's a
brilliant idea yep so I don't know
exactly how they do it but I'm assuming
that means when you post a link it's
just going to show the body of text not
the headline
because what they tried doing first was
it was like you didn't read the article
would you like to read the article first
which I liked what I love is uh I'll
give you an example The Daily Beast ran
a fake story claiming that I was said
Tim Paul was accused of stealing a cat
the real story was random person lies
police confirmed lie we ran headline
anyway
and so this is what they do you make a
headline Twitter at the time before it
was X put the story in the what's
happening page for like two weeks and it
was the weirdest thing I'm like what
what is this and then the story at the
bottom it's like police confirm it's not
true and they're alike but we'll put the
headline anyway well that's my question
because
if you're going to do the body of the
the story I want it to be paragraph
eight if possible yeah because if you
read the articles usually the Articles
the first couple paragraphs line up with
the headline and as you keep reading the
second half of the article disproves the
entire First Steps welcome to Modern
journalism right but so which part are
you going to actually clip as the
preview which is a complete nightmare
are you gonna do three random sentences
which could be interesting or one it's
just the opening paragraph because
you'll you won't get full contacts it'll
just say something like today Donald
Trump had appeared at the Fulton County
courthouse and Dot
well there's such lighters they'll say
um shameful guilty scumbag president
showed up I mean they literally are just
trying to figure it out yeah yep yeah I
love the uh the fact Checkers trick the
classical move where they'll do
something like
you know Donald Trump will do a backflip
off of the White House and land
perfectly and then Snopes will write did
Donald Trump do a backflip perfectly off
of the White House onto the lawn on
Sunday and then they'll put false and
then they'll give this big long-winded
explanation and very all at the bottom
say well he did do a backflip it was on
Saturday
and so they add context to a story that
no one offered and then claim it was
false because the context they add I
love it I'll give you another example
actually is uh Biden falling asleep
you saw that video you mean he's bowing
his head in solemnity solemnity if Biden
falls asleep and what do what does
everyone say he's falling asleep he
appears to have fallen asleep yeah for
like 10 seconds and then obviously in
the video he gets back up I counted it
it's 10 seconds then his eyes open he
coughs and then he looks up and I said
he looks like he's falling asleep what
did NBC News claim they claimed that we
said he was sleeping outright they said
he'd no he's not that well we never said
that he pulled out a pillow laid down on
the ground took a nap said he was
falling asleep he clearly is and they're
like in the high resolution video you
can see that he opens his eyes and it's
like we all you got us we're we're
totally misleading you but they lie
Davis they claim what we've said was
more extreme than what we actually said
and then fact check us it's just
absolutely insane also couldn't like I
think you tweeted about this but
a lot of people doze off in meetings
while sitting still especially people
who travel and work a lot like he didn't
snap on the ground like these things
happen instead they freaked out and both
said you guys are lying also he was
being very respectful like he's just
really old and probably should not be
living the lifestyle that he's being
forced to live right like that's it and
you guys should accept it but they can't
because they can't admit anything is
wrong with Joe Biden because he's their
incumbent and they have to protect him
at all costs like they're they're doing
a lot of crazy stuff to Republicans but
Progressive leftover controlling the the
Biden White House are also in a terrible
position they do not have a strong
candidate going into 2024 that's why
they're so desperate
well they do have a guy who's kind of
running around and we're still trying to
figure that out why is Gavin Newsom
running around the country campaigning
without actually campaigning isn't it we
know where it's going what did Trump say
about Gavin Newsom the other day on the
Tucker interview
it's like I always actually really got
along with them we'll see it's gonna be
interesting yeah I think
I think it's reasonable to say Biden is
somehow removed from the race in one way
or another and then Gavin Newsom steps
in my my my my theory I don't know if
you heard what I was saying about this a
few weeks ago the best way for Democrats
to pull it off is for Joe Biden to have
a medical episode on stage at a
California rally where Newsom is acting
as a surrogate and then Newsome Runs Out
rolls up his sleeves and does CPR and
Joe Biden saving his life Joe Biden then
says you know the the difficulty in the
strain has been too much for me and I
can't you know blah blah blah but Gavin
Newsom has proven he's the man for the
nation he does a press tour everyone
says you saved the president's life what
is that like and he's just like you know
you got to do your duty in this country
that's that's PR gold you you could not
hire someone pay someone there's no
amount of money that would give you the
historic PR I have to imagine honestly
too if that really did go down that way
Joe Biden has some kind of medically
faints or something and then there's
panic and everyone's screaming and like
we we've all seen him trip but like so
they're primed for it a more serious
thing where like grips his chest and
then he stumbles down and falls and the
crowd gasps then Gavin Newsom runs out
and saves his life
his his favorability goes up to like 63
his approval rating among Democrats goes
up to 99.9 he then says you know I never
wanted to take the job this is not my
intention or my plan but I will not let
you down Joe and Joe's going to be like
thank you except for Kamala is going to
be on the side with the with an ax going
no I don't think so unless the Supreme
Court Justice happens to be removed at
the right time she's not going to go
away quietly because she's part of the
alternative action in California but I
think I I think she does as she's told
and the question actually is how do you
get past Kamala because if we're going
in order of succession in any normal
political uh circumstance if Biden is
out for any reason Kamala is next no
she's there I mean the second he stops
she's there so he has to but say I'm not
running again but stay alive long enough
for it so what happens is Biden doesn't
leave office he says you know while I'm
recovering I think it's fair to say that
I will not see seek re-election due to
the you know the concerns that people
have for my health but I believe Gavin
Newsom is that proven leader and Kamala
will agree you cannot beat that PR I
don't I don't see any other way they
remove Kamala from the equation without
looking really weird and clumsy well to
build off your theory uh uh chief
justice Breyers is retiring at the end
of this term right so theoretically they
could say Kamala you get to be on the
Supreme Court like to your point this is
actually happening yeah and then she'll
be like I don't need to run president
I'm going to stay in the Supreme Court
forever I think Gavin Newsom is like
great great I will become president
nominate you and or Joe Biden I guess if
he's around depending on when his you
know medical emergency happens I mean
they really do have this set up where it
could work all the Supreme Court's
justices get lobbied to stay or not stay
depending on what benefits the rest of
the party Kamala could say something
like you know I was here for Joe
and you know with everything that's
going on I am overwhelmed and or she
stays on his VP and says I think being
the vice president and having Gavin step
in is is is fine I have a two-term VP
that'd be crazy I cannot see that
because I understand she and Gavin are
not tight so Supreme Court Justice I can
see them giving her that I mean that's
life but that means he needs a different
VP and she has to leave for some reason
but but I I agree I mean it's it's it's
I I can't think of a scenario in which
they can successfully
have Biden not run
and if they don't then Kamala doesn't
run they've got barricades here yeah
Biden is they have no choice what are
they going to do if they pull him out it
looks weak and it's uncertainty and
people are scared of it at the very
least they might lose votes Trump might
not gain votes they might lose votes
if Biden's out then it's got to be calm
life it's not common with what's
happening like how do you how do you
have Biden and Kamala not be running at
all and it's Gavin and someone else well
and Biden said explicitly you know one
of his his goals was to have uh you know
more diverse people representing the
party at the federal level so to a
certain extent people are expecting to
become for a lot of reasons she just
didn't work out the way they wanted her
to like she would never pulled in a
popular way she does not have the
Charisma to carry off the presidency uh
but if they can Shuffle her off they can
power broker her into the Supreme Court
maybe they'll be able to pull someone up
from the bench I think Gavin Newsom will
have challenges all the time because I
think the Democratic party does is sort
of split on the face that they'd like to
see in the white house but he is the
only person on their bench after the two
current president and vice president and
he's going to debate is he still
debating his hands what's up with that I
think so which is weird I mean think
about that for a second because again
he's not running but we do have
precedent
remember I said 1968. right yep well
what did we have in 1968 an extremely
corrupt president who did not have the
best health who stepped out of the race
and then we had a Robert F Kennedy enter
the race and take over so
LBJ and Biden are really similar there's
a lot of parallels there the corruption
the family money the TV station and uh
and how long was Kennedy in before LBJ
uh
two three years yeah yeah it like was
not a full presidential like run so you
get Trump in for a year and then Biden
steps in so there are other similarities
in the duration
politico's reporting that the Gavin
Newsom Ron DeSantis debate is at an
impasse because of issues Fox is having
so it was planned for November but I
guess it's like maybe not gonna happen
Okay Gavin Ron come on down we'll do it
we'll turn the camera on and go live
culture war no but in all seriousness
it'd be cool if we did but how hard is
it for them to turn on a webcam and be
like let's talk no they have to use
mainstream media too otherwise you're a
fringe right-wing candidate that's right
that's right from I understand DeSantis
isn't going around on podcasts anywhere
so he's finally learning I guess now but
he seemed to be allergic to it oh man
Vivek is hitting the nail on the head
with the hammer he's been going on every
podcast he can he went on Alex Stein's
live show and that got asked about 911
they're using that against him yeah but
vivek's just like I'll go on anyone's
show like let's get the word out I think
Vivek understands the balkanization of
media spaces and Bobby Kennedy
absolutely yeah both of them uh I mean
oh yeah podcasts are gonna play a huge
role yeah in this election yes obviously
I can't remember if it was vague or
Larry Elder that week that we had both
of them on but one of them was talking
about doing the podcast like a podcast
style thing like fireside chat from the
Oval Office like it is cool to see these
people Embrace new media especially as
we can see I don't know that fox will
ever go completely away all entirely but
it doesn't have the power it used to
let's talk about this uh story we got
here the Georgia judge sets October 23rd
trial date for Trump co-defendant
Kenneth chaseborough
I think that's something y'all should
consider let me first give you a little
context a Georgia judge on Thursday
signed off on a quick turnaround to the
start of the trial for Kenneth
chaseborough one of the 18 defendants
charged alongside former president
Donald Trump in connection with the
alleged efforts to overturn the 2020
election the ruling scheduling October
23 start date came to stuff for Trump's
newly appointed attorney said he would
move to sever the former president's
case from chaseborough or any other
defendant who sought an expedited
timeline
what's what are the chances and I
understand some people might say it's
not legally possible I don't care
what are the chances Kenneth Chase Perot
convicted
convicted November
and then they say
Donald Trump was charged for the exact
same things
and if this guy was convicted Trump
should not be on the ballot either
because he's a co-conspirator we we
moved to 14th Amendment his name off the
ballot he accept he's charged not
convicted doesn't matter Trump shouldn't
be charged in the first place his lawyer
should be charged in the first place my
point is this
several months ago if I were to tell you
they're going to indict Jenna Ellis for
being Trump's lawyer people would be
like well they can't legal counsel is a
protected is protected in the
Constitution and then they did so
they'll have their PR excuse but I don't
know Donald Trump was The Mastermind but
can they charge someone's lawyer Jenna
Ellis is accused of accounts one and two
literally being part of a criminal
experience a conspiracy and solicitation
of a violation of oath of office
literally just because she was Trump's
lawyer other people in the charges were
reaching out to people and asking them
to do things and Jenna Ellis's Council
counts one and two
we said this months ago oh they can't
indict Trump performance never happened
but then they did that or a year ago
sure we oh they're not going to go after
his lawyers they are I said next up is
Media personalities now we're hearing
James O'Keefe is under investigation
criminal investigation in New York it's
going to keep happening that's why I'm
saying like
yeah maybe maybe the legal theory is
Trump's not been convicted but the
argument they will make is Trump was The
Mastermind who ordered Chase bro to do
these things for which he's been
convicted that proves it as far as
anyone needs to understand that Trump is
an Insurrection I don't know that it
matters because Eugene B deps
Eugene B Debs was a socialist who ran
for president multiple times from prison
there's precedent yes but they'll remove
his name from the ballot under the 14th
Amendment Trump can run all he wants and
they'll say yeah that's fine but your
name won't be on the ballot because the
14th Amendment says you're an
insurrectionist you can be a socialist
in prison and still run that we know but
they're they've already done this to
um
what's the guy's name in uh uh New
Mexico you know what I'm talking about
New Mexico politician got removed from
uh the election because they called him
an insurrectionist they tried using it
on Marjory Taylor green and Madison
cawthorne you want to look you look at
it but he's not convicted what I'm
saying is that
if he's not convicted technically until
he's convicted how do you remove a Snape
from the ballot he's still charged you
can't say moving someone's name from the
bound to the 14th Amendment would be
novel
well everything's novel so much exactly
and so the issue is this what's his name
it's um
coup Griffin Griffin yeah Coy Griffin
that's right he they said he was an
insurrectionist so he's ineligible now
Donald Trump
is The Mastermind of the conspiracy who
gave the instructions right
allegedly allegedly and if this guy is
convicted
what does he say in court about what
Trump told him to do
and then they can say this is not about
a criminal conviction of Donald Trump
this is about a statement of facts sworn
under oath that Donald Trump instructed
an individual to assist him in
Insurrection thus disqualified uh as an
elected uh to run for office his name
should be removed from the ballot I'm
not saying that they might not try that
but that's one of those where you got to
get really black pilled I hope at some
point the Supreme Court's saying well
he's not convicted yet dummies I mean I
mean let's hope that maybe the cover of
the Constitution can remember not but
I'm not talking about the criminal case
I'm saying in this criminal trial of
Kenneth chaseborough he will be asked
what did Donald Trump tell you
thus they will launch a civil suit
against Trump outside of any
requirements of criminal conviction to
say
witness testimony in a criminal case
Trump instructed these people to engage
in Insurrection adding on top January 6
statements people storming the capital
all of that they'll play Clips out of
context this will add to we're not
trying to criminally charge him that's a
totally different case we're saying he
waged Insurrection therefore he's
ineligible yeah I don't know that's
where I say please get Robert Burns in
here and ask him that because but it's
not a legal question it's a political
election law well it's election law too
I mean
considering they've indicted Trump's
lawyers I don't think it's a ballot
access is absolutely election law right
but
they could do anything they want because
the law is not
is is not written by the Lord law is
written by men and is ignored all the
time yeah the fact that they've arrested
Trump's lawyers
sets the standard they can do anything
they want they will make up whatever
they want so my question is just you
know maybe you're right maybe it's just
this is the line where they say well
we've we've violated the Constitution
we've increa we've created new novel
ways of of Prosecuting people but this
one time we stopped well I'm kind of
hoping that this fails I mean it is dark
obviously they're arresting Council and
I find it completely disturbing and I
hope there's a backlash and that's why
I'm pissed off about a lazy ass Congress
that's not pulling her up there because
the feds need to be coming down and they
need to be saying what the hell is going
on the state managed to get it together
they managed to get two houses in
Georgia itself that is landing an
investigation of her we've got this
problem why isn't Jack Smith under
investigation why are we being so damn
lazy on one side well maybe because we
really kind of like the idea that
Trump's getting put away maybe we kind
of want another candidate to come up
there maybe we like you know hey there
is only one side though
exactly sure so they're they're sitting
there going like no wait don't Democrats
and we're going yeah you tell them and
then they go to the same parties and
hook up with the same escorts and drink
the same wine and what they hate drugs
they hate the people
yes
yep plain simple I mean even if they
don't hate the people they're at the
very least not interested in serving the
people and interested in maintaining
their own power and staying in
Washington DC and you know eating the
good food and living in the nice places
and going to the nice places and stuff
so you know and they're indifferent to
the you know to the what is actually
legal you know what the law says these
are the people that when you go to the
halls of Congress and knock on the door
and you walk in they're all smiling and
saying how can we help you and you're
like I just wanted to you know leave a
letter for the congressman lebeg thank
you so much and then when they walk out
they'll go when they start wiping
themselves off and the congressman pops
out and goes oh it was in here they
don't like you these these people don't
like you there's like 12 members of
Congress maybe 20 that like you
overwhelmingly they don't they're all
you are is a number they're having
meetings with their consultant saying
look I just want to get more votes what
do I need in their life people like red
have you considered wearing red you'll
get more votes that way they don't go to
someone and say what you constituent
you're a farmer what should I wear a red
tie or a blue tie so I I don't think it
matters I'm wondering why the prices are
going up for my cost for my fuel it's
like okay well I'm gonna wear the red
tie that's what they are
they're not actually they're not
actually I this is why I think we were
talking to
um return to Freedom caucus okay I can't
remember which one
he said that they had the votes to
overturn Obamacare and Republican
leadership came to him and said but
don't do it because we're going to use
this to campaign
they do not care about you
that's it's just it's got to stop man
and I don't know that Maga is it but
certainly whatever it is populism is
bringing is politicians who are actually
talking with constituents and maybe this
is it maybe this maybe it's social media
for all of its uh for all of its
negatives has some positives in that as
we form our own communities where we
care about issues the representatives
that we elect share share those values
in much the same way because they're
part of the same Spears no you had a
sponsor right you were just talking
about what Public Square yeah
well that's power I mean what's
happening with Bud Light is a real thing
yeah and I really do believe Andrew
Breitbart was correct when he said
politics is Downstream of culture yep
and if the culture divide we've got a
show about culture
that's going to push the politics
because they can't afford to keep going
against it if the culture turns they
have to go with it ultimately right so
we agree you've got to change the
culture I completely agree
that's everything that's why you know
most of the stuff most of the stuff we
do here we'll talk politics but most of
our investments are not political I see
no point I've donated to political
candidates a bunch of times but I don't
see a real point in doing that I'll put
it this way Tucker Carlson where is he
more most effective doing a show or
being president what do you think sure
absolutely the cultural force of him
coming out and talking to people and
inspiring people way more important than
signing an executive order Oliver
Anthony you're a band absolutely he's
he's most effective when uh he has a
show and Trump is the president because
then Trump just listens oh yeah well
there's that too that's a cultural
pipeline yeah Trump's on Air Force One
just watching Tucker Carlson that's what
he did he's got someone taking notes for
him while he shows down yeah I wish we
get some like behind the scenes footage
of them hanging out in Maine while they
like film that interview no they were in
Bedminster oh they were I'm pretty sure
Tucker went to New Jersey
yeah I don't think Trump's going to
travel to
you know I just know that's where his
studio is or elsewhere here's another
thing to consider maybe the real reason
or a reason Trump didn't go to the
debates there's no way he can go to
Milwaukee debate and then fly to Atlanta
the next day turn himself in I heard it
was pre-recorded though no no I'm saying
if he flew to Milwaukee for a live
debate oh well yeah and then he left at
midnight and flew back and then he has
to fly back the next day
that's brutal but he was saying that he
wasn't gonna he wasn't really interested
in doing the debates for way before
Georgia right he could have turned
himself in before or whatever yeah well
and like he has been saying I don't see
the point of this I'm clearly in the
lead all of you guys are just going to
you know try and attack me like I it
doesn't it only benefited the RNC if
Trump won because more people to watch
and fox yeah you saw that they they
wouldn't let Don Jr in and Kimberly
Guilfoyle which is Chris and Larry Elder
which by the way I'm super annoyed about
that I'm really annoyed because you had
Tim Scott seems like a great guy but
come on if you could have Tim Scott or
Larry Elder in a debate now hold on
there a minute I would not mind Tim
Scott's actually pulling really well I
think he I think he's doing better than
a lot uh Chris Christie
I'm just saying any of them but I'm just
saying well Hutchinson come on come on
speaking of that Larry Elder is Leaps
and Bounds above all of them
Democrats are going to try and field
Newsome which he directly challenged
Newsom Like Larry Elder should be on
debate stage because he is interesting
he's representing California I think
he's well spoken he's got a lot of a lot
of power but also if Gavin Newsom is the
future of the democratic party because
we don't think Kamal Harris and Joe
Biden are really going to be able to
make it to the next term Larry Elders
exactly who the RNG should want on the
stage I don't understand why that's not
obvious not only that the way two of the
candidates got in there Hutchinson and
Bergen both bought the donations with
gift cards right yeah which is
disgusting so you have Larry Elder who
actually did get the donation the
old-fashioned way going on The Breakfast
Club having to fight with others coming
on Tim cast IRL several times
versus these people who are literally
saying hey if you donate a dollar you
get a 20 gift card two candidates out
there and nobody's talking about it
yes the only way the Republicans they
they love getting pushed around by
people playing dirty money
yeah it seems crazy and they're they're
like oh the pole this is the issue like
I just I don't understand what the
Republican party's issue with Larry
Elder is and I think that they are
hurting themselves it's you know I have
maintained for a long time that debates
are boring they're ineffective like
everyone gets four to five seconds to
see we raise our hands like it's
ridiculous but if we're gonna have them
at least have people on stage who first
off people are donating for too but also
who are advocating for interesting ideas
like that's one of the reasons Vivek is
performing so well he has all of these
interesting approaches I don't agree
with everything on his platform but he
is a breath of fresh air Larry Elder is
uh you know he's been talking about
politics for a long time he's got really
interesting positions on immigration and
on school choice I don't understand
family right why would the party not
want him there especially when he played
by your rules not only that he's very
conservative I mean Larry Elder is a
main line
family oriented old school conservative
he and Ben Shapiro walk the same path in
many many ways so it it's mind-blowing
why they don't want him in there
man no it's not Justice for Larry Elder
you know what I mean
oh well for real I mean he he he would
have been amazing on that debate stage
yeah they they are playing dirty I can I
just say I loathe
the the RNC
Rana McDaniel come on we could have had
Army Dylan I hate her Army Dylan is
active engages with people she
communicates she fights she would have
been way better for RNC chair
nope
they like losing
but I don't think they're actually
losing I think it's uh Washington
generals
oh whoops
they're supposed to lose that's it yeah
it's just sad because I think we should
want to hear about ways to help the
country and the people who have the
Innovation who have uh the
the drive to sort of push push the
envelope to really think about new
things are not being given this
mainstream platform of course I believe
there are alternative ways to get your
message out there but it is annoying to
see people shut out from this party that
is saying well we all have to pledge to
beat Biden but they are excluding people
who are potentially offering ways to do
that I have an idea why maybe I just
thought of it literally
Larry Elder preaches Independence like
people to
meritocracy people to stand up for
themselves and to achieve
what they're seeking
and if people are achieving things for
themselves running their own business
doing their own thing they're not
dependent anymore on the government
so people like Larry Elder are truly a
threat to the unit party whichever side
it's on because he's preaching
Independence yep yeah let's jump to this
story this one's really interesting it's
uh it's political but not related to the
debates or anything justice department
sues SpaceX for discriminating against
asylees and refugees in hiring that's
right ladies and gentlemen Elon Musk
hires too many American citizens for
this he is being sued the doj from the
lawsuit of government yup department is
that from September 2018 to May 2022
SpaceX routinely discouraged asylees and
refugees from applying and refused to
hire or consider them because of their
citizenship status in violation of the
immigration and nationality act Ina in
job postings and public statements over
the several years SpaceX wrongly claimed
that a federal regulations known as
export control laws SpaceX could hire
only U.S citizens and lawful permanent
residents sometimes referred to as green
card holders export control laws imposed
no such hiring restrictions this is
absolutely insane
SpaceX is one of the biggest contractors
with the US government I mean it's
literally NASA it's essentially it's the
reason that that Americans can get into
space uh I I it's this again I think
this is political I think this is the
federal government going after Elon Musk
because they don't like the things that
he's doing uh in other areas I don't
think that it has anything to do with
SpaceX uh Behavior I think they're mad
about the block button yeah if you bring
that back right now maybe Twitter files
too I don't know
um but yeah I mean that's that's the
long short of him he's cutting them off
from their information pipeline or is it
X-Files X-Files now yeah think about how
easy it would have been if you're in the
intelligence agencies to get information
because you didn't need a warrant they
just handed it over now Elon is dragging
his feet or outright saying no and
cutting off their access so they're like
let's get revenge but also consider this
think about the political ramifications
here
Elon Musk didn't hire enough
non-citizens for his company in the
United States that's another thing that
blows my mind they're talking about
non-citizens there was a time where I
thought it was illegal to hang and to
hire people that are non-citizens I mean
obviously right that's what I thought
you know
well yo like what
so I could just hire anybody I want now
we can we can get all our video editing
done and Peru apparently save some money
Chinese video editors
so they're saying please contact their
civil rights Division if you applied for
a job at SpaceX and were rejected you
were discouraged from applying because
you're not a U.S citizen that's what no
I love that civil rights by the way
civil is part of what we're wait
civilian
that's right I'm very confused
no it seems ridiculous I mean
I I think the Biden Administration
obviously doesn't care about the
American worker I think if he did he
would bring manufacturing jobs back from
other countries and I think this guys of
being like well we're
anti-discrimination is actually another
form of let's make it more difficult for
American workers to get a job and that's
kind of disgusting for this apparently
working man blue collar or whatever he
claims to be president how big of a deal
do you think immigration is going to be
on the election you think it's going to
be it's not going to be big enough it
never is right and you know Ann Coulter
was saying it's the key issue and that's
the issue that helped Trump win in 2016.
but I'm not convinced I I talk to
regular people and they never tell me
that's a concern they have
what's a swing state issue so right
borders will Arizona be in play I don't
know Texas is going to pretty much
probably stay red but Texas is purpling
over time
um Florida is not changing because they
had a problem immigration worked against
them
they they get the wrong countries
because remember they they love
immigration but they don't like humans
okay as an example because Cubans are
not the right kind of immigration for
them
they vote the wrong way exactly somebody
made a good point
uh lior engelstein and Super Chat said
alternate headline doj Sue SpaceX for
only hiring U.S citizens to work on
potentially classified military
technology yeah I I thought that there
would be itar stuff is what I mean that
makes sense to me international trade
and arms and stuff like the this is all
rocket technology this stuff is all
about you know all of it's like got some
kind of classification whether it be
secret top secret or whatever it's it's
not information the feds want spread
around I don't you know I figured they
would they would have have it under the
Arctic stuff you think they care they
think they'd want to be secretive I mean
I you buy night vision stuff you put you
can't you're not supposed to take that
out of the U.S you can't sell it to
people that aren't U.S citizens you
there's lasers and stuff like there's
all kinds of infrared stuff and that's
just like small arms stuff that like I
mean night vision is cool but you know
you're not gonna get a nuclear weapon
into space with them you know yeah so
yeah I have no idea and it's confusing
you're a military right no I mean not
seriously like I was in the military
when I was a kid like in the 90s I
didn't do anything like there was a
whole war that I had nothing to do with
so I don't like to talk about like doing
anything because I did nothing well you
and I both okay I was in the 90s too but
we had itar and then I was working for a
defense contractor I don't know how many
courses I went with itar you cannot
release the information to anybody this
is just a defense contractor and it
could be toilet paper they were weird
about it I think Elon is extremely
disruptive to a lot of the narrative
machine a lot of the establishment and
we're probably going to see a lot of
moves that make no sense being made
against them this this one right here
makes very little sense I it reminds me
of what they're doing to Trump right
like they are desperate to make
something sick they don't like people
who challenge their narrative and so
anything that they can say you know this
uh South African native is
discriminating against in immigrants at
his company like they just want him to
be the bad guy and they'll do whatever
they can to get the headlines right I
mean and they'll keep they'll keep
they'll keep doing this I mean X is
paying people
this is that's huge people are gonna
start using that platform for a lot of
things it's going to cause a rapid shift
in our culture in that people are
engagement farming and things like that
but for the most part
when we talk about how do you wake
people up to what's going on politically
in the past couple of weeks I've been
saying tell your friends and family to
sign up for Twitter AKA X because you're
not gonna be able to convince them Joe
Biden did bad thing but you can convince
them to sign up because then they can
show you share stuff with you so when
you're talking to your your you know
liberal aunt or uncle and they say
something like yeah well Trump did this
would be like oh I didn't hear that he's
like you didn't hear it how did you not
hear him be like why don't you sign up
on next you can send it to me like here
send it to me on x31x you're not well
sign up so you can send me a message
then they're going to be on then they'll
start getting access to a wide array of
information I'm not saying to make them
conservative or anything like that it'll
just make them go oh yeah I did see that
video and then you can at least you
don't gotta argue with them that it did
or didn't happen
well that's a good approach for that
reason yeah I think Eli is in the
crosshairs is an understatement but I
don't know what else they can do
let's see what what musk can do no what
they can do to musk I mean we'll see how
we'll see look I gotta I think all of
the stuff they're doing in terms of
indictments the targeting of uh all of
Trump's allies and his lawyers this it's
desperation it's pure panic yeah looks
like it
I think it is for sure I mean that's why
I am convinced that although a lot of
stuff is happening to Republicans you
have to keep looking at Democratic party
and saying you guys are going on the
offensive because you actually don't
want to be on defenses because you would
fail right you don't have a strong bench
you don't have strong candidates Joe
Biden's record is not good and so
they're actually going into this
election I feel like and I'm not an
expert in a very weak position and so
unless they can get Trump indicted
unless they can take out this uh super
performing candidate who is likely to
win the nominee they are sort of stuck
they need this to happen otherwise what
are they going to do
yeah and if they can bloody them up
enough and stall him enough I mean a lot
of it's just maybe they're thinking
eventually he'll give up
I don't I don't think you will no run
out of money Bud Light Target sound of
Freedom Richmond North or Richmond
cultural victories across the board and
this and this matters when they say that
12th grade men are skewing conservative
consider that in the 2024 election 12th
grade boys are old and are going to be
old enough to vote many of them already
are and they will vote for Trump there's
a reason why they become conservative
hey maybe they're watching too much
Andrew Tate I think this is why they for
real though the reason why they banned
him so quickly and rapidly across the
board before like he's gaining tons and
tons of followers but he wasn't cracking
into like the the political Zeitgeist
but he was building influence and also
they just ban him everywhere
yeah because he's getting a bunch of
young dudes yep to like start listening
and they're not gonna vote liberal
Democrat whatever
can't allow that
Jordan Peterson too yeah just recently
yeah now Jordan Peterson has to be
re-educated yeah that's something man
I think that I really wish that
Americans would pay a little more
attention to uh what's going on in
Canada because where
in the Hat oh
it's really our Americans have a hard
time paying attention what's going on
Canada personally because Canada seems
irrelevant to them but also Canada is
always trying to be like aha but America
is the crazy place I think they like to
direct attention away from themselves we
we do we declared our independence from
Canada after inventing corn syrup
because you know we had to get all our
maple syrup from Canada and breakfast
you know what are we supposed to do and
Canada had that strangled then once once
we invented high fructose corn syrup we
could make fake syrup and put maple
flavor in it and that devastated the
Canadian economy but it freed the
Americans for to have uh breakfast and
Vermont agreed because they're like fine
we will be the only place you can get
real maple syrup we'll we'll have a
monopoly on it oh it was big it was big
Vermont maple that spearheaded the
campaign on Maple now Maple's super
expensive you know it is I have made all
that up none of that I'm kidding I hope
people realize that no it's 100 True Tim
is a historical uh corn syrup maple
syrup uh conflict expert I will say we
got some of cousin T's pancake mix and
stuff sent to us I'm really excited
we're uh we're waiting for Terence to
come on down and which is hilarious
we're gonna make some for breakfast he's
so are you familiar with Terence
Williams and the thing he did with
cousin T's so after Aunt Jemima got
pulled the image from all of these you
know syrup bottles and boxes he made his
own pancake mix it's actually legit like
the ingredients are legit it's not just
like basic nothing it's a lot better
than I think the ninja mimos and uh he
put his face on it and uh uh it's
absolutely hilarious I am deeply
offended that they removed Aunt Jemima
from my pancake syrup and my pancake mix
because I liked Aunt Jemima yeah like I
don't know I was just like the thing at
the store with a little breakfast I'm
like oh look at that and then they they
start removing anybody who's not white
from all these products
it's just the most racist and insane
thing I've ever seen but anyway Terence
he he uh made his own and we got sent
his breakfast syrup and his pure maple
syrup
and immediately you know everyone here
being as snooty and as scared of seed
oils as they are they were like whoa
corn syrup what is this and I'm like to
be fair cousin T's lower cost breakfast
are up is just corn syrup it's not high
fructose corn syrup and regular corn
syrup is actually not that bad it's the
high fructose stuff that's really really
bad but he's not he's not a crazy guy he
has pure maple syrup too which is
expensive to get so we have some of his
real maple syrup and some of some of his
corn syrup but uh once he comes down
we're gonna have him on the show we're
gonna film in the morning as he makes
pancakes for us shows us how it's done
it's gonna be awesome I'm really excited
for that anyway let's read some super
chats if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this Channel and head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member and we're gonna have a members
only uncensored show coming up for you
in just about a half an hour and more
importantly for all of you who didn't
already you can purchase your tickets to
the Miami event October 6th they are at
timcast.com in the menu bar timcast X
Miami you click that and uh we're gonna
have Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr
and Matt Gates with Luke and I we will
be uh we'll be hosting the event
beforehand I don't I don't want to say
too much about the fall details just yet
until we can confirm everything but
we're really really excited Public
Square is sponsoring it because we are
just absolutely huge fans and I'll say
this the guys over at Public Square we
are lucky to have you guys as sponsors
because we would shout you out either
way so the fact that you're helping us
put on the show is just icing on the
cake when we talk about winning the
culture war and everything we have to do
the guys over at Public Square have
created the easiest way to win the
culture War you download the app Public
Square and you can look on a map of all
the businesses that share your values so
you can avoid bad businesses that are
going to use your money for bad things
and support businesses that agree with
you and your values and that's how we
win parallel economy so I'm super super
excited and honored to have them
involved we got a bunch of cool plans
too giving out uh Swag Bags and things
like that so it's going to be a whole
lot of fun I'm really excited for Miami
and uh I think you know October is
probably a good time to be down in Miami
it won't be too hot it'll be cooling off
a little bit
all right let's read some more I'm not
your buddy guy says collectivists across
the West seem to be okay with sending
their political opponents to jail or
Worse their removal from existence we
must realize the and then just cuts off
oh there it is fight is now and whether
I like it or not the US should it fall
there is nowhere you can escape to in
the globe The Last Stand is now
I think every it's important to clarify
every time what we're seeing with these
indictments with you know going after
Elon fear it's afraid Bud Light probably
set them it terrified them these these
these woke organizations they're losing
their grip on the institutions I mean
it's the craziest thing to me that
skateboarding went woke I'm like you
mean to tell me the guys who post videos
to this day of them punching security
guards committing crimes and bringing
law are terrified of saying naughty
words well I don't want to lose my
sponsors I can't tell you how many Pros
I've met who are like
well you know like we'll skate we'll
film but I can't speak up because I'll
lose my sponsors and I'm like why would
you lose your sponsors that's like the
weirdest thing it doesn't matter
we got to keep our heads down and I'm
like okay dude but you know whatever I
do think it's turning around a lot of
big name skateboard Pros are not just
being like dude I don't even care
anymore I'm sick of the weird nonsense
that's going on
let's read some more
Jonathan e says rip Dave Smith 2024 also
I found your video on the install woman
I've uploaded it and DM the link to you
and Brett on Discord oh cool right on
man thank you so uh what Dave Smith's
not running is that confirmed yeah he's
not right he formerly on he formerly
anti-announced yeah so yeah we were all
sitting here like Dave announce already
ah for real
by his wife is his he's got a new baby
and his wife is like you know we can't
again the baby has had heart problems
there's been surgery so it's not just
it's not the right time for us yeah it's
not a small thing it's he's got real
serious who's gonna who's gonna run uh
candidate I don't know I've heard rumors
but where's Luke at Luke run from
president he can't he's polish yeah he
wasn't born here right no no so he can't
I think I think he said he's like I
can't he's like I was born in Poland I'm
like Oscar Peterson greatest he could do
it again Austin Peterson yeah he ran in
2016. oh okay
he's not he's not running either he
hasn't been sniffing around at all oh
come on we got who there's no who's
running tell us I can't tell you right
actually I don't even know that I don't
know that they're running I've only
heard a rumors so I can't say Phil knows
for sure everyone DM to Phil right now
are you seriously saying that are you
serious don't DM me if you knock it off
like I have uh stop I have stuff to do
this weekend
are you kidding me don't eat no he's
just being Coy
I have to drop him on Twitter I used to
have this friend named Hannah Claire
admit it were friends no uh now we're
best moments it was moments it was like
today was the day I was like maybe she's
got oh
friends don't DM him he likes to keep
secrets it's fine
it's fine all right Nova says Ian talks
about forgiveness for Democrats but
can't do it for Trump trump said 15 days
to slow the spread but reversed quickly
Ian can't move on Obama murdered
children and Ian calls for forgiveness
his bias is disgusting I completely
agree and I think that having him on the
show to say that allows us to articulate
exactly what you explained that
otherwise people would not hear because
we'd all sit here and be like we
shouldn't forgive Obama you're correct
next subject Ian then says no Obama were
like bro Ian he bombed kids that it
brings out it it's it's like a little
salt on your steak you know it brings
out the flavor maybe a little lava salt
you need different perspectives for sure
and Ian does that yeah and and Ian
there's you know he's just a regular
dude right except the hippies like no
but I mean but I mean like he's not he's
not a hyper partisan leftist or
right-wing guy he's not super in line
either like a lot of this like this
exactly the stuff that he's familiar
with when it comes to culture War stuff
it's not because he's actively looking
for that stuff on in his spare time or
whatever he hears it here yeah true yeah
let's grab some more kick the ball says
Trump is old if he dies for any reason
while in custody he'll be viewed as the
assassination of the gop's primary
political candidate for president where
do we go from there
yeah I mean the fact that they've
arrested him already dude
four times crazy
Trump is old but he seems much healthier
than a sweet sweet Biden oh yeah yeah by
the Fireside says Trump gets arrested
and imprisoned the entire 2024 election
wins in a landslide and is released the
morning of his inauguration emerges
totally jacked covered in prison tests
and ready to exact his Vengeance on the
Deep State dude I'm imagining it like
kind of like Fast and the Furious
he comes out with a gene vest his arms
all ripped and just ripped and he's like
let's oh someone made the Revenge poster
yeah Revenge poster you want to tweet it
or something or just post it we'll be
like
print it out use it revenge and the
funny thing about that that mug shot is
it's kind of menacing like he's looking
down at you with the what's it called
the Kubrick stare or whatever that's
what it looks like is that what are the
kubricks there like if they lose that
might give them nightmares
Revenge I gotta tweet it out I'm gonna
pull it up
I'm gonna I'm gonna tweet that out for
everybody let me uh sorry guys this is
it would be more important yeah it would
be extreme where was it where was it
posted uh she just sent it to me I'll
send it to you oh yeah oh there it is I
got it oh wait is there a better one
than that one she's saying uh that
there's competition from our company
Trump's on Twitter is he what man he
controls the media that guy what hold on
he's like I got arrested so I've
returned to X wow that would be amazing
it would be hilarious
oh Donald Trump just tweeted no no
Donald Trump tweeted we gotta get this
ladies and gentlemen hold on
breaking news and it's oh my God
mug shot August 24th 2023 election
interference never surrendered Donald J
trump.com I want to put that on a team
it just went up a couple minutes ago
heads are exploding let's go that's sick
I'm gonna like that right now that's
crazy okay I gotta quote tweet this with
the picture that says Revenge I just
sent you you sent it to me yeah because
the one you showed me looked really good
yeah it was like a bunch of different
versions I'm gonna tell you guys right
now Tim doesn't like Chris bertman's
version of it he likes Jessica's version
of it I can't tell you did you message
it to me it's taking a little while to
upload throw in shape I know you got to
get oh there it is
okay this one's pretty good
let me just download this uh image right
here Donald Trump has tweeted that's a
big image God I hope he pins it Elon
Musk just finished I really want to
I really want to put this picture on a
t-shirt this is the funniest thing
because it's also slightly Boomer you
know yeah
that'll be so hard just that I'm like a
white T-shirt yeah I would buy that
Trump is back wow also huge controls the
media like he knew if he got arrested
but I'll be watching and then he got
back like you know this is all Orchestra
he knew as soon as he got on the plane
to go down he was like and tonight I get
on Twitter yeah he definitely like
rehearsed this look that look is
menacing oh that's so funny nice I like
this yo holy crap I think this is going
to be the most viewed tweet in his in
history yeah sorry x-post
it's been up for four minutes got 15 000
reposts 5 000 quotes 10 000 likes since
the time we've been sure Brian
krasenstein within a minute or two says
welcome back signed your worst tweet
mayor
he's back
oh man all right well you know elon's
dancing on the streets oh yeah oh God
yeah all right we're gonna go back to
the old super chats I wonder if Elon
probably knows already someone's like yo
Elon what if Trump told him he's like
okay I go in tonight my mug shot comes
out I come back on X and Elon is like
okay sounds great and tomorrow Elon is
bought truth oh my God
we will grab some more Smothers says
stop pretending the Supreme Court will
let Trump be put in jail yo they could
have just put him in jail they arrested
him the Supreme Court didn't do anything
to stop it the question is if he's
convicted do they stop from going to
prison Trump is facing felonies which is
prison not jail difference jail is
typically uh uh uh slight under a year
and prison is a year or more yep
uh do you want the Revenge picture to go
on Teespring I mean I don't I don't I I
guess we could sell a t-shirt I just
gotta I can do it in five minutes but
you could talk about it later I don't
know I said yeah go for it I just kind
of want people to take the image and use
it and just do whatever they want with
it like everyone can just make their own
but I guess we might as well sell shirts
yeah I gotta say his return to to
Twitter x with this particular picture
with the with this whole thing the last
time that he tweeted was three you know
three years ago and it was I'm not going
to the inauguration and then the very
next tweet on his page is his effing mug
shot there's nobody hard nobody better
oh my god oh man yeah plus with the
lawyers you just hired too dude that's
hard
amazing all right let's grab some more
here it really was a historic night
Trump returned to Twitter yeah
the 13 we can crap crack open oh my gosh
Steve McGee says six three 215 pounds
what an absolute unit Ian weigh in 145
is victim weight
yeah
there's there's no way he weighs that I
mean they had to avoid him I don't know
they didn't weigh him they just took his
word for it yeah probably that seems
it's like all fake I I've seen I'm six
too and believe me I'm well north of 215
pounds yeah I know yeah yeah I mean
Trump's tall he's tall
215. he's got to be 250. right there
lying it's just that his suits have a
lot of volume in his hair has a lot of
volume so you guys think he's bigger
than he is well there is uh we don't
have the G Prime 85 comic but it's the
one where it's uh Trump he's really
really small and short and they're like
sir are you ready for the debate and
then he's like bigly and then they lift
up this very tiny three foot tall Trump
and put him into a into a mech suit yeah
and steam comes out
you know that's possible
here we go David Walker says I'm a
Chilean that views U.S politics instead
affects us eventually I watched the full
Trump interview I am not the only one
yeah so what they're saying about the uh
Trump interview on X is that the total
views are actually closer to like I
think what do they say 16 million actual
views and uh the Tweet views are
different from the video views but this
is the thing that I think
you know Impressions right
well they're tweet views impression
impressions are
another way of saying it but I think
Impressions implies someone didn't see
it right if you are browsing a website
and there's an ad on the left side
that's an impression an ad impression
that's technically the same thing as a
tweets you're scrolling past but a split
your scrolling past is in your field of
view that you're actively choosing to
move past so slight difference I think
tweet view is more appropriate what it
means is the view count on the Tweet
shows you how many people saw that tweet
not the video the video was uh 16 times
it was uh I was off a bit I said I
thought it was going to be maybe like 10
or 20 percent and so I was like maybe 20
to 30 million in fact it was a little
bit less than 20 million actual people
who watched the full you could release
that I mean Elon
they could track The Click how many
people actually clicked on the video
what's the CTR on that you know you can
watch the interview without clicking on
it
okay that's that's the thing too so I
just think the the left is trying to
undermine it and the right is trying to
tout its you know importance but the
numbers are the numbers man
we will grab some more Super chats what
do we got Sparky says bongino thinks
Trump shouldn't have posted bail but the
ability to communicate from inside of
jail is limited to making working on a
Case difficult not if you turn the whole
jail into your house yeah like you with
this with you know security with the uh
Secretary of service yeah right
that was the point that bongino made the
the Secret Service could have just taken
it over
okay Eric Blackwood says when Trump gets
elected Tim should be his press
secretary never that'll never happen I
would never never get involved in
politics only in like the periphery
perhaps like interviewing somebody or
something like that like we've already
done but
I think anybody who wants to be involved
in politics is
unwell
unwell all of them
and yes that includes Trump
the man's got something going on up
there isn't it true that
um if you're into personality tests the
Myers-Briggs Personality set test says
that the personality type that Hillary
Clinton is is like specifically
congregated in DC like there's a serpent
certain type of Personality that ends up
wanting to be in polished demons
oh if that's what's classified as I
think it was like intj or something but
you know right apparently uh Trump is
speaking on Spaces there's no next oh
wait what yeah that's what that's what
Chad's saying I've seen it a couple
times wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait hold on how do I pull this up
I don't know chat let us know
I will I will pull it up on my phone if
I have to can you just you can't pull up
spaces on
yeah the type of personnel
hold on hold on hold on I want to hear
myself talk Trump is speak wait what
yeah that's what I see in the chat I
just put a prince
no no this is not Jerome Powell so he's
a parody this is fake oh are you
watching this right now this is the
actual space yeah okay so this is where
the audio is coming from
have to make sure
no that's not him come on come on come
on come on
um Jessica says it looks like she can
put up the PDF on Teespring for free of
her of the Revenge image so like wait
what do you mean like you can buy the
buy the shirt or just download the image
yeah she's working out right now we can
talk about it in between the show keep
an eye on the Teespring because we'll
have some stuff there I guess I say we
sell the shirt but like open source the
rights that anyone can put on any shirt
they want I don't care well I think we
put it up in our in our merch store so
that you can easily get access to it and
buy it if you want but I would really
love it if people just used it it's not
the most original idea it was like we
were all just joking about it it exists
it's very you know low effort I just
find it really funny yeah
it would just be so cool to like be
walking in a city and see like four of
them on like the side of like a light
post your like the transformer box or
something like on the you know post no
bills and then there's like Revenge yeah
what they were doing with Obama you know
what I mean sure
Revenge that's gonna freak them out
they're gonna be like Trump's back
make them into stickers and like post
them on college campuses everywhere oh
God
I need a safe space could you imagine
the college campus that would draw more
hate than it's okay to be white
seriously on my college campus one of
the someone in a
street level dorm room had a picture of
trump in their window and used to have
to walk past it to get to one of the big
parking garages I always thought it was
so funny Noah Sanders says just got my
ticket for the Miami show so excited for
the event just wondering are there any
VIP tickets that might include a meet
and greet I only saw general admission
tickets but would gladly upgrade if it's
available
I can't confirm anything just yet
because I saw the talk to everyone about
the plans but I think Elite members of
timcast.com are going to have special
access to something or other uh there's
limitations to it obviously because we
can't just be like you know oh look if
you're an Elite member you can just come
and do whatever you want come hang out
but I think there is a plan
I don't want to tell you to go become an
Elite member right next I don't know for
sure but if anything does happen it'll
be elite members elite membership is a
hundred bucks a month or more and you
get access to the elite members Discord
where there's a lot of cultural stuff
going on and uh basically more plugged
in with all the crew here and the
projects we're working on and special
access trials demos stuff like that but
what we want to do is we want to make
sure
I mean we're trying to get this place
open we're trying to do a club a skate
shop a coffee shop all these things and
uh elite membership is supposed to be
like a core Community thing where
everyone gets to be a bit more involved
in everything that's the purpose of the
support level I'll just leave it at that
give me uh some a couple days to confirm
with what the plans are going to be when
we're down in Miami and there may be
some limitations but
I think there may be an Elite member
Meetup
let me just confirm and get back to you
guys I don't want you to like spend
money yet until we know for sure but I
think it's likely uh I'd have to confirm
with the organizers our crew the people
who are setting everything up to know
how long do we have the venue for what
are our plans uh so yeah we'll figure it
out
Evelyn Grace Arellano says my husband
and I love all of Tim's Impressions we
are really missing Mrs Pelosi's
appearances you should do one uh she's
just not here she's not relevant anymore
yeah she's no Congress but not the
speaker right you know when she was
speaker she was in the news all the time
she talks like this Donald Trump is the
worst president and it should be
impeached that's my Nancy Pelosi it's
intentionally bad and meant to insult
her so you know there you go
no
all right Sparky says the left are a
bunch of Cairns that's mean to people
named Karen I've never liked that it's
like I met a woman named Karen I was
like I feel so bad
called Karen
no that's that's a mean mean word
all right we'll grab some more
Raymond g Stanley Jr says I mean Gary
Busey still has the best mug shot
that was a crazy mug shot yeah
Isa says Tim make it say rage instead of
Revenge that way it stays a four-letter
word uh okay why don't we do both well I
don't know it's got to be one we if we
make two people will grab it and they'll
change it anyway probably yeah rage is
good though but I feel like revenge is
better rage I get in a lot of ways it
makes sense because you had hope now you
have rage but I want Trump to get
revenge
you know and the menacing look he has is
perfect yep it's perfect Revenge I
seriously wonder if they were like um
flying down he's like do you think I
should smile do you think I should do
this face like I want to know if they
were like having a conversation about it
because you know this tweet they were
like prepared to have yep
it's the same thing like all the
political Consultants Tim Stockton
earlier who are like should I wear a
blue tie should I wear a red tie always
go with the red Power tie yeah except
for it depending on what event you're
doing for some events they're like we'll
wear blue so you look you look very calm
and peaceful you don't want to seem
aggressive
do you think Trump is gonna
oh so there's a message I'm gonna read
the message for you guys he because that
was part of the Tweet he says a personal
note from president Donald J Trump today
at the notoriously violent jail in
Fulton County Georgia I was arrested
despite having committed no crime the
American people know what's going on
what has taken place is a travesty of
justice and election interference the
left wants to intimidate you out of
voting for a political Outsider who puts
the American people first but today I
walked into the lines done with one
simple message on behalf of our entire
movement I Will Never Surrender our
mission to save America if you are doing
poorly due to the Sinister people in
control of our country right now don't
even think about donating but if you can
please make a contribution to evict
crooked Joe Biden from the White House
and save America during this dark
chapter in Americans history thank you
and God bless and he's asking for money
hmm yep that makes sense that's about it
there's a bunch of uh asking for money
uh you know I've never given any any
money to Trump I'm considering it now
though considering the charges I'll
probably end up giving money to Trump
I've never donated to Trump before just
don't give it to the Republican party no
I can't that's why when I hear them say
like yeah but if you've done it to Trump
he's going to use it for his legal
defense and I'm like bro I don't care
what he does with the money if I gave
Trump 20 bucks got the eyes on a good
job and he bought an ice cream Sunday
with that that's cool fine well I ain't
complaining about it let him do his
thing you know what I mean
where are we at
km says finally Eric Hundley the goat
Rancher's version of Christopher Langan
is on timcast Trump mugshot versus Shea
Guevara t-shirt or Trump and Breitbart
War I I absolutely love the Breitbart
war clip yeah it's just so like his face
so good
oh man crazy
where are we at
Jason Hutchinson says I'm disappointed
Trump's mug shot could have been that
cheesy grin with two thumbs up that
would have been great dudes but I'm kind
of glad we got the menacing look because
we can you know make the Revenge poster
and I think it does add solemnity to
what's going on you know it's we are
always very solemn yeah he looks pissed
that he got arrested in general yeah yo
he's gonna make so much money off this
Yep this is what he was waiting for with
his tweet I bet like everyone's like
he's got to come back he's got to come
back he's like I'm gonna come back when
I'm gonna make money yeah that one that
one acts everyone saying he's back he's
back he's back and it links to uh if you
can give me money give me money I wonder
where's adcut's gonna be from Elon does
he get profit sharing how many
Impressions do you think he's gonna have
on that I mean serious yeah no I mean
let's be real Trump will probably make a
million bucks a month and that's he
could fund his campaign from X that
would be great well to be fair he's
gonna need a billion dollars for his
campaign but a million bucks a month
ain't nothing a good start and all he
has to do is post yes think about
that I mean I got paid five uh 4 400 and
that's basically all I do
so it's like I don't know if you post
nonsense and no it's not fair like I
post some like legit things I get a lot
of retweets well imagine if he posted
his earnings too that would just make
people bonkers
hey man there's an opportunity I I like
the idea that people were uh sharing
clips from the show
and then getting views on it because
it's free marketing for us yeah and I'm
like I'm kind of torn because I don't I
don't know if like what the
ramifications would be if I was like
yeah take Clips in the show because then
we don't know where they end up yeah but
I'll say for the time being
we reserve All rights that being said
when people are like I've clipped the
show and ended up making money because
people are watching the video I'm like
that's good like free marketing for us
we don't got to pay for it and you're
advertising us okay congratulations keep
the money otherwise what I got to pay
you the hundred dollars to make you get
the views for it you just get the views
for it you keep the money yeah works for
me
let's see what we got cap 303 says you
think the Trump team hasn't worked this
out they probably told him to Mean Mug
the camera to go with the slogan that
they had ready already printing it mean
mugged the camera the the problem I have
with that idea is like that implies that
Donald Trump listens to people right no
I think he was sitting there being like
what do you guys think I should do I
think I'm gonna go with this one and
they're like yeah he might ask people oh
he's already made up his mind
yeah true like so many Executives in the
world I mean you know Gitch says poor
Ben Shapiro he's been chugging the
copiolite desperately saying all the
Republican candidates did really well
except for Vivek during the debates what
I I is that true is Ben really saying
that because I got to tell you like it's
objective Democrats Republicans
moderates Independence everybody uh the
data that the New York Times put out
showed to make was polarizing in that he
gained a lot of new supporters but also
gained a lot of detractors he gained
more support than he gained detractors
but he polarized and uh I think DeSantis
according to their time uh the time uh
New York Times gained a little bit and
his unfavorability dropped a little bit
so I wonder if DeSantis play was to kind
of like let someone else blast off a
little bit and then neutralize the view
of you to a certain degree either way
that's kind of what he did well Jordan
Peterson had a criticism of a Vivek and
I think he's right the Vivek could have
gone a little easier like when he said
all these people are paid off he could
have specified people yeah which Trump
would do and
he's right I mean
eventually he's got to work with them at
some point if he's trying to move
forward and that is a bit of a youthful
impetuous response but overall he got
the attention and he did take the arrows
and he bought his way back yeah all
right everybody if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends and head over to
timcast.com and buy your tickets to the
Miami event now available and open to
the public we gave members the head
start but now anybody can pick them up
we expect them to be sold out probably
by tomorrow the event we did in Austin
sold out
I think in like a day and this event
let's just be real we got Patrick Bet
David Matt Gates and Don Jr they're the
stars who is an honor and a privilege
that they would join us on stage for
this event me and lucrutkowski will be
your host for the night but I have to
imagine this one's gonna sell out quick
and we're trying to do really really
really awesome stuff for everybody in
the crowd we want to give a bunch of
free stuff away uh shout out to Public
Square but uh become a member click join
us we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show coming up for you in
just a few minutes and uh then we'll
take calls from you the members you can
submit questions and uh we do about four
or five every night so become a member
it's really fun on the uh uncensored
show you can follow the show at
timcastirl follow me on X at timcast and
Instagram and uh Eric you want to shut
anything out America's untold stories
please check it out if you like
historical things you want to learn
about LBJ and how bad that dude is we
have a Trilogy on him of him and his
women and did he kill JFK right on
that's awesome well it's been super fun
to be here with all of you on this
historic night when Trump returned to X
um I'm Hannah Cliff brimlow I'm a writer
for timcast.com you should go follow at
timcast news on Twitter and Instagram
you can also find us on the website
teamcast.com you click on the read tab
you can see work from me Chris Burton
Adrian Norman Cassandra McDonald
occasionally Chris Carr some other
people it's an awesome team to work with
I'm grateful to be a part of it if you
want to follow me personally I'm on
Instagram at hannahclared.b and on
Twitter at HC brimlow thank you so much
I am uh Phil that remains on X I am
Philly remains official on Instagram uh
you can follow the band on Apple music
on Amazon music on YouTube on Spotify on
Pandora on all you know the internet so
and I am surge.com I'm excited for the
after show today was crazy and I'm
definitely getting one of those t-shirts
because that is gonna go so hard I hope
yeah I'm like I think I have the link
right here yeah our revenge t-shirt I
think it's coming up on our Teespring
any second as soon as updates yeah I'm
gonna buy that as soon as I can I want
this Trump
tweet on a white plain white T-shirt
Jessica I'll tweet this out in a second
I'll tell you all to become members at
timcast.com so we can see you in the
members only show then I'll tweet it out
thanks for hanging out cheers